all right so
um we are now at the closing remarks we
just got through 40
speakers
[Music]
and so we have more than a thousand
people here actually as you probably
learned at registration you know
actually we had more than 12200 people
and there were so many more want to come
so whatever we do you know next we'll be
in a bigger venue and whatnot which is
great so the movement is absolutely
growing um and uh so what I want to do
just you know you've had tons of
lectures and and and uh content and so
on and so forth I wanted to give a few
very quick slides and let's get to
hanging out and connecting with people
for the next couple hours and then uh
lots of folks are going to be around in
Amsterdam for the evening and for the
next few days so lots of network State
connections okay so just some close
closing remarks so basically um you know
uh two things I have for you okay uh an
exit pole and a paron gift okay so the
exit poll is very simple um just scan
that QR code or go to the network.com
frpo okay um you might also take a photo
of it and uh then you know uh like like
QR code scan it later in the event that
Wi-Fi is flicky or or cell reception is
flicky or something something like that
okay this will take you about maybe 10
minutes to do um but it's actually
essential for turning what we're doing
here further I mean we've already
started turning it from Theory into
practice you've seen a lot of literal
concrete getting poured you know in in
some of the talks here right um and a
lot of you know thinking on how do we
make this work for security and how do
we make it work for mainstream how do we
make it work given the political
environment and so on and so forth but
this exip actually helps in a different
way which is it helps us understand
where the community is at okay so we ask
some basic questions like you know just
your contact info like uh you know your
your eth name or your salana name we ask
you know what country or what city
you're in so we can pick the next venue
um we ask for feedback on the conference
itself and any you know if you've got a
great tweet on the conference or you
should tweet it on the conference if you
haven't tweeted on the conference go and
tweet on the conference and then paste
in the link to the Tweet so I want to
create a page of all the tweets so then
that'll be you know like a kind of a
nice souvenir like a like a record of
what everybody thought at this moment
like putting your John Hancock on the
Declaration of Independence kind of
thing you know um and uh but the fourth
thing that's on there is actually a list
of sort of polarizing questions and the
reason I'm asking a bunch of these
polarized questions you can of course
ask answer na to them but the reason is
as I mentioned in the poll there's
something that Scott Alexander calls a
scissor statement right and a scissor
statement is something which uh one side
thinks is obviously true and the other
side thinks is obviously false like um
you know well is is Thor a God or not
that's an that's a non-controversial one
from the olden days okay and people
probably came to blows over that um so
the reason that we we've asked a bunch
of uh the sort of political questions in
there is that what we're doing is
inherently political and I want to
figure out um how to avoid unnecessary
scissor statements figure out where the
center of mass of the community is what
things do we have consensus on and what
do we somewhat disagree on and then try
and figure out okay how do we how do we
uh you know optimize for that Center of
mass and I have a mental model of where
I think all of you guys are in terms of
being well I don't want to prejudge it
okay so um so exit pole for a reason all
right so please do this it'll help us a
lot and as an added Sweden ER okay um
you know I'll actually I'll give you the
Parting Gift even before you complete
the exit poll but are you going to raise
your hand can you guys raise your hand
say you're going to complete the exit
poll please raise your hands okay thank
you very much okay so please do complete
this here's your Parting Gift okay so
it's a network.com frole here's your
Parting Gift uh so he did this
completely of his own accord I did not
ask him to do it Eric did uh the Nalan
act that sold a million copies um and so
he of his own ACC Court did the
anthology of biology and he's such a
great guy and I was thinking you know
all the Jos who hate Tech all the guys
who are haters I have to spend some
Cycles on them why not spend time on a
guy who's actually like a great you know
great guy and so so um so Eric wrote
this book um which is actually it's
really as much Eric as it is me because
it's kind of a compilation of um like
tens of thousands of Snippets from
tweets and podcasts and so on that he
found interesting and it's always
interesting to see what others find
interesting um so that QR code if you
scan that you get the first chapter it's
online anthology of biology it's also
got the illustrations by Jack butcher
who many of you guys know from crypto
who's an amazing artist and I think it's
actually a amazing piece of work um and
this is like a prequel for maybe the
network state hard cover or what we
might do there okay and a lot of other
things coming there um that's a parting
gift so you guys all got the screenshot
of that yep good take a photo of it if
you haven't all right
um and uh that's a wrap but one last
thing which is um we we are actually
making the network State movie and if
you guys want to be in the movie I'd
like to take like a group selfie of you
okay so if our camera guys all right
there camera guys coming
great so uh we was going to do a few
like first I'll like kind of stand like
this you guys can say something you know
maybe I don't know uh say Network State
I know we said that a few times but it's
good for the one more cut for you know
the the official movie and then we can
come in and get a group selfie if you
guys want to do that okay so let me do
come on in come on down yeah we're doing
this all together all right and then
don't follow the stage that's the key
thing that's right come on in come on in
how should I post should I just stand
like this can you angle it properly okay
great sit down if I sit if I sit I don't
know if I don't know his camera angle
okay okay great okay
great yes of course I'm going to do some
MH I know it's not that kind of audience
no no CR surf okay
great all right we got it we got it this
is like the ultimate like you guys know
the AI thing which is like uh the Norse
vikings in the in the boat you know
right you know like ancient Egyptians
right so this is the future we good we
also have to thank the streamers oh yeah
what the streamers all the people
watching in t oh yes of course streamers
uh QT QT this QT this if you want okay
this is great all right guys so we I
think we got we got the content oh okay
one more all right okay oh my God
everybody wants to take a selfie now
okay so um should I turn around okay
good one two three all right one two
three nwork state can we get one more
all right ready okay one two three
networks
day all right that's okay
great